hello and welcome to the lobby
gamespot's weekly hang out every Tuesday
a2 p.m. pacific right here on gamespot
com I'm your host Daniel Dwyer joined
this week Chris waters isn't here oh my
god it doesn't matter we got the
original operation anchorage right here
Justin hey wall how do you deal my
friend I'm good and the pride of Utah
antibes Allen hey what up how are you
great at first off I want to talk about
a little thing called 4k oh yes you made
feature last week on gamespot com I
drove into that [ __ ] you did you you
you made a great excuse to play as many
games in the workplace as possible look
I'm so busy I have to play this but for
Kayla snow I'll do myself all right all
in the all in the the the aim of
answering one question is 4k worth ish
and so first of all Justin actually what
is 4k for those who are uninsured hell
this mean I I think that it's something
from the future yeah so right now we're
in 2k yeah we you know we're previously
in 1k or in the 1000 to K games and
we've pulled technology from 2,000 years
in the future and that's all fort man
that's right man this up video games
look like 2,000 years in the future I'm
gonna be bummed at 4k is how many lines
of resolution we talking about it uh
2160 so 2160 vertical so it's about 4 x
rays it's exactly 4 x 1080 okay so you
can fit four 1080 screens in 14 ok
screen alright so you played a bunch of
games on in 4k last week yeah captured a
little footage what games did you play
ok I got my notes you got your notes
because I played a lot I'm good actually
yeah I played Wolfenstein yeah I played
far cry 4 project cars dirt rally GTA 5
and the witcher 3 which are all games
i've been playing a lot lately not in 4k
yes so i could have like a frame of
reference going into it i do games
support that right like 4k is it's not
like you can just play an nes game I
don't like oh it's 4k yeah I don't know
about that like who knows these are all
games daily no games it will scale maybe
that natively had it in them well then
whether or not the textures yeah are our
4k resolution is that so precious to
what's what's going on behind the scenes
yeah [ __ ] droids way but uh I know
what's going on in the settings menu
yeah i'll let you select for ok so you
figure all right before we get into
how it looks it so it's subjective that
I'll say that yeah I had a different
experience than like garce our man Josh
pretending to track don't worry we'll
get into that yeah I want to talk to
about that let's let's have a look at
the technology first of all right you
bought you bought a couple of treats
here's what I wanted to cover hmm to run
for K we have this beast of a machine
yeah it's it's an alienware alpha I
think it's called or something like that
anyway area 51 yeah i mean the alphas
the little guy thanks bro yeah it's like
45 hundred dollars yes yes we r 3 gtx
980 s running an SLI which is possibly
the best 4k solution here's the sexy
shots that Josh Shaw took of it for the
residual cards you can find on our web
site 39 80s which is like be car right
now right it's like the best card
besides the tight necks yes okay which
is a single card basically solution for
doing this super-high stuff like 4k this
is a thousand dollars I just looked at
the price for the show ten fifty one
thousand dollars fifty couldn't even
shave off the 51 just like oh my G lean
on the 1980s are five hundred sixty
dollars each right now okay so two of
those will have probably outperform one
of those right but you're still paying a
little bit more um okay but under that
yes guys this is the focus more if the
cost is super high no no it is already
graphics card exactly yeah you need to
eat a Model T you need to have a now for
the monitors so we did our testing on
this guy which is a acer as you can see
thank you just a gaming monitor 28 and
28 inches for okay 60 Hertz okay pretty
good yeah it's pretty self juicing right
now I want to getting too deep into that
but it adds about two hundred and thirty
dollars to the cost of the monitor
g-sync juicing get this monitor for four
hundred and fifty dollars without do you
think okay and you can get it for 680
something concerned eighty-four dollars
with g-sync what is it weighs different
what is did you think is its some sort
of okay so g-sync works with other
nvidia for stuff yeah nvidia stuff and
it kind of it makes it so if your
monitor drops if your framerate drops
below the refresh rate of the monitor
say 60 in this case if you're running
like 40 GC kind of takes over for vsync
and is
doesn't skip it doesn't make like a
skippy motion like the velodrome so it
eliminates fraying tear frame tearing
yeah visually and it eliminates the
frame skipping which you can feel and
see you know in the game and it seems to
actually work like I've seen demos where
they show off like here's g-sync on
g-sync off for you've been doing it much
more extensively than I have do you feel
like it actually adds to it so no but
again it's there's probably deeper stuff
to get into a sink and in our case
running SLI there's juicy stuff in the
drivers give her a performance hookah so
I turned it off to get the highest
performance I could get and honest I
didn't see any screen tearing on that
model some people are more sensitive to
that another sort of resolution versus
frame race but when we when we captured
the output of those three g9 80s
whatever on a device we had called a
Shogun which the whole different thing
there was massive screen tearing or on
that thing which it wasn't showing up on
that monitor so maybe that monitor is it
was running do you think and I just
didn't know it what about this guy ok
this is this is you want to talk about a
new like smudging my Trojan horse for
this piece ok to talk about high frame
rate ok with just almost it's like the
opposite side of the argument but yeah
it goes back to like the age old pc
gaming debate of do you want to have
more pixels on a monitor do you want to
run fast exactly and in the era of like
LCD panels we kind of we kind of lost
that everything is 60 yeah yeah we kind
of just said 60 is the highest thing you
can get yes I frames a second like
consoles are trying to get their
consoles have to like sacrifice together
right run at 60 I remember having CRT
monitors that were like 120 Hertz like
it's 21 inch and that was like and we
were like happy back then but then you
can kind of like it gave you like a
headache sometimes oh it wasn't perfect
oh it sucked one of those filters on it
where if I touch the gamey stomach Sean
yeah it's gotta be Gaza Bell yeah I'm
dying yeah but anyway so monitors have
started coming out super high for every
Mars 144 hurts so it's 144 which is true
hurts like you see all this BS mark yes
all over TV that's like 100 food for the
head ones for 3d so I don't know if
those were like really running out of
court for their like doing something
there's a whole lot of split down the
middle when it's 3d it's not it's like
so
but this is like yes the frame rate is
that high and boy can you tell the
difference I can the can is subjective
right playing this game dirt rally which
is phenomenal game early access um at
over a hundred frames per second yeah
was game-changing literally like I
played the game better because I could
see things happening like it was
smoother i was like 'i braking power
sliding way better i don't know why
maybe it was just a feeling was better
and i wasn't really playing better but I
is so cool it's one of those games where
you are like looking at a specially
driving games rear you're looking at a
point in the distance which is quite far
away so like having that little bit of
reaction time my mind and even in FarCry
4 just seeing the bullets hitting and
like being able to react faster and it
was smooth when you would do like a 180
was just so cool like there's something
unexplainable that just makes you feel
amazing when you're playing it over 16
you know there's probably internet
debates about if I can't see past six
yeah I totally can 100 frames 100 plus
all the weight 144 it's incredible I
thought I would much rather go for high
frame rate sign for K at this point but
I I feel like this is like the the blue
and black gold and white dress of
[ __ ] video games because there seems
to go on forever where people are like
like when I was like looking at the 4k
stuff when you show me that it was like
some of those like and you ain't even
into like parchment cars at 100 frames
no not that's the way that as much as I
was but I think framerate is always
where I've landed on like I feel like
the arguments on forums for years and
they're just everywhere is it's an
age-old debate that almost says
something it's just so personal
preference e to Justin really land on
this whole thing you know for me it's
something that it's so new that and
there's not a lot of games that
necessarily take that much advantage of
it and and you look at all this extra
stuff you have to throw on three graphs
and make it worth like yeah does that
price really I'm add to that much more
of your enjoyment I mean yeah cuz pc
gaming cool i want to know what's beyond
1080p60 like and so I wanted to achieve
I see it and it's amazing like like you
know how people talk about this stuff
all over like 900 p on the xbox we're
hitting super like you know really high
into these consoles and they get really
passionate
about it I kind of like didn't I was
like always not like understanding why
they were getting so up and now I'm like
the one that's gonna be like no I need
144 today there's also a 2k monitor
that's eight hundred dollars that runs
at 144 that seems to be the pinnacle of
pinnacle she's a me tries to get that
cuz running shoe k is pretty good on
even like a 970 really yeah Oh see
that's where I'm out yeah I'm excited
these are the type of games I play
actually probably matter a lot more like
I love shooters I love car games I love
ya action games I love city skylines
what kinda game is at that pride doesn't
matter no so they sell matter is modesty
your way and what may be in 4k that
looks amazing I didn't I'm sure and you
know what this is ever a problem is
while I'm sure if you bought a fork a
car for scars of a a monitor you make
sure that everything looks great even if
it doesn't you tell everyone looks great
I got no buyer's remorse over here
here's an interesting side note we ran I
was like Mortal Kombat is going to be
great at 100 frames per second it was
capped at 60 because I guess where the
fighting is just that's part of the
design so maybe this is something we can
look forward to two years down the road
or at least pc gamers can look for ya
tears on the road this is probably gonna
look with it I didn't really get into
like what 4k looks like mmm it looks it
doesn't add let me to my interpretation
of and everybody was different of course
because we all have like different
things we care about but playing on a
monitor that's like 28 inches that close
up your desktop is unusable right yeah
that small everything's tiny but once
you load up the game and stuff it scales
but then every all the objects and
everything in the game take on this form
that you're like whoa I can like grab
that so so it seems like it's something
that's like so Chris it's less important
for for that console will XP refer
that's sitting in front of our monitor
experience but when we start getting
into VR when those experiences get
bigger and bigger and cheaper like then
4k feels like it's going to be
incredibly important oh yeah like
because then you'll be right in your
foot the massive part the problem we
haven't had oculus is that they're
splitting this one halfway there already
like they can get the rod that's a
conversation for another day Andy what's
the name of the feature people can watch
on gamespot all about friday i think i
ended up naming 4k gaming how cool is it
ok or something like that and the answer
is awesomely cool especially our friend
Josh in there let's go same before love
the witcher 3 a fork yeah he was like
and I didn't look at it because I'm
playing on xbox one do my dope I won't
it yet you know poison well cannot go
back SSO if you want to watch the
feature tip on gamespot com right now
and let us know in the comments what you
think I'm sure you will I'm sure the pc
crowd will let us know have more and
we'll be back in just a minute we're
going to check out a trailer from Mad
Max and then we're going to have a
little chat about whether video games
are to violence in the wake of hatred
which is coming out next week stick
around here's my max the game not the
movie
life is a savage road out here a man
with no wheels is a man with no home I
know you you're the driver where is the
car you're black on black is scrapped
dawn she'll never be whole again it's a
long dark passage from which there is no
exit
there's something brewing out there
this land is about to be scorched by gas
down wrath
in these wastelands the righteous path
is whichever road gets you out alive
I see what's behind the crazy in your
eyes
Lord scrotus got hurt you or you could
ever hurt me
rolling
hatred the video game is there next week
on steam it's not coming out on gog.com
they won't have it on a bunch of
websites and article especially the
mainstream press in recent weeks have
been getting in a kerfuffle about this
game which basically involves you
murdering a hell a bunch of civilians oh
don't civilians man violence in video
games have we gone too far Justin you're
obviously keeping your finger on the
post newswise what do you think about
the kerfuffle that's surrounded hatred
well so the problem isn't that you're
killing civilians we kill civilians and
tons of games great auto is about can I
mean is not about killing civilians it's
more how incredibly realistic help for
me like I had a very negative reaction
to watching the trailers you're not just
kind of mindlessly bowling over people
who are mannequins were just like joke
characters you're shooting people in the
face were fighting in who are saying no
who want to hold onto their lives and it
makes it kind of terrible you're just
like I'm gonna go in a room like why are
you doing it because I'm crazy gotta go
kill people who are crying and you're
gonna shoot them in the face like so
you're saying you're saying it is if
it's [ __ ] up and mad kind of sandal
arias to me in a weird way but you're
laughing yeah I'm kind of laughing it
does sound like it might be too like I
can definitely see how somebody showing
this footage unlike CNN my piss people
off it's quite baithi that way yeah but
do you think it's do you think like this
sort of violence is too much in the wake
of like you growing up like where their
games that you thought were too much
because like we go back and think what
the fun and games back in the day where
you think carmageddon soldier fortune
postal 2 yeah so as your fortune moments
great you shoot off the limbs with a
shotgun definitely playing that when I
was like 14 or younger maybe so but I
will say this when i see Mortal Kombat X
right and I think about like kid playing
that today that's like way different
than when we're playing Mortal Kombat my
mom was like hey that's pretty gross
like you should major clay fighter
instead yeah well you know not somebody
and then
three gallons of blood flow out but it's
like oh it's all very pixelated
incredibly fake but in the new one man
when it's like kind of detailed
animations are good as a great sound
design like whoa man as a key like I
guess it's not that much different cuz
still cartoons that's the that's the
thing but like is it I don't know it
gets cartoony but it makes real like
when you rip off somebody stole it's
like oh that looks like the inside of a
skull and brains and that's that I feel
really weird about this because like it
whenever we get into this area of all we
shouldn't accept that or like we should
hold games up to a higher standard like
it not it would but people say that it
like it sounds like what like [ __ ]
in the mainstream media used to say
about games like GTA we're like you just
you just you don't understand that when
we play these games it's not like it's
really not really look at this this is
basically a high-res version of postal
one like this looks like post them it's
an isometric shooter we're barely has
any color in it and it's you know you're
just mowing down a bunch of people like
this look that bad like I think the
gameplay is fine it's it's more what
I've seen in the trailers that may
hatred less palatable less that it
doesn't seem like fun like I'm gonna I'm
in a playground of kind of ridiculous
destruction for me that's never been a
pole like I don't go in a mortal comment
like oh I can't wait to see these
evisceration all this gross stuff but it
was my idea me like I don't care you're
all for that's why I'm oerlikon by don't
play really fighting and I don't play
Mortal Kombat I don't it doesn't look a
lot yes got right in his eye right it's
better like I talked about like kids
nowadays but as an adult yeah you should
be able to do it you play like this line
right wait why are we even talking about
these things in terms of kids because
this is an automated game yeah yeah but
if the game is fun what you probably
wish it might be trash but it might have
looks like I was what if it's kind of
cool and then it's like and then it
makes you like feel bad for killing
that's kind of powerful like cuz it's
like aww please don't kill me and you're
like knife in the eye so that's that's
kind of powerful I don't know it's more
powerful than something like postal 2
which is a game like despise you every
yep I really loved it I thought it was
so funny and this is a game where you
can we're looking this is postal 3 here
at
these are games were able to like
they're just so dumb like to everyone
thought was super violin because you
could like piss in people's mouths yeah
it was a button for peeing you could
under your zip and pee you could set
people on fire with a flame thrower and
then like pee on them to put the mares
maybe it's on the face of it that's cut
look at this guy's is spring but I don't
know buddy squirting on this don't wanna
know and but it's not like it's a new
thing I mean even looking but like not
just postal but call of duty is
something that that stands out to me
that as soon as they started putting in
those really violent brutal hand-to-hand
kills like when you open a guy you just
Jab a knife into his neck and draw it
across I'm like I I don't like to watch
that in movies I I'm not gonna look away
i don't care it's not bothering me but
like I don't seek it out I don't want
that really a lot of animal crossing and
that's my speed yeah right at first
person GTA was another one where it like
stuff looked real nasty but I feel like
that was worse because that world feels
real whereas there's nothing a bad
hatred that makes me think this looks
like anything other than just a
Psychopaths fever dream in fact one of
the lines from the developer our site
this is actually from em from Wikipedia
and the player controlled character is a
misanthropic mass killing psychopath who
begins a genocide crusade to get as many
human beings as possible the developer
described hatred as a reaction to video
game aesthetic trends such as political
correctness politeness vivid color and
games as art so the top three sound like
animal crossings you must be pretty
paste and whereas that games as ours
like in a weird way he's making like an
artistic statement as games as being an
artistic statement with an artistic
statement like yeah that's what if
that's what they're doing then this is
the most pure form of games as ours man
people are called games art I'm gonna
make a piece of art in the palm of a
game yeah to show them yeah like I don't
have to be or it kind of would be
interesting if what you're saying like
if it does make you feel bad yeah well
that's up to that's that's what's great
about games everybody feels different
right but it I'm all for pushing the
envelope like yeah I grew up in an area
that super conservative right and so
like I felt like I needed to push push
things and offend people and movies I
made were super violent for like no no
other reason that
it was cool for us it's like that's what
we wanted to see I want to see game like
that and I'm may be calming down from
that more and more as i get older but
like yeah violent games there's a place
for it yeah there's a time for it I
don't think that I'm gonna go out and
MIT to everybody but I guess I just did
on the lobby but like am I gonna go like
tell everybody that I meet like hey I
love this game it's the most violent
game I've ever played um no probably not
but it's like something I definitely
check out and be like you school yeah we
haven't gotten to the point yet where a
violent game can be heralded as
something like wonderful like think of
some that killed Bela for instance which
is like two movies of really not
mainstream reason like hey look this out
of the last of us had incredibly violent
scenes and the way that you murdered an
eviscerated freak Atlantic but and it's
still critically lauded and yeah a great
game that's a really good example
actually yeah about to see if hatred is
another one of those for what is the
next class I'm not saying it's gonna be
the new last night but it could
surprises we don't know I guess we'll
find out next week it's available on
Steam and it's not available on GOG it's
on desura as well GOG have decided not
to according to the developer that they
refuse to distribute the game and but
yeah we'll see hopefully there might be
a good game behind it not just a bunch
of press and fun and marketing we'll
know in a couple days but let us know
what you think in the comments below all
right next up cyberpunk 2077 the corn
went down in a second we went to see the
project and saw some interesting stuff
and with the news today that they're not
going to talk about it for two years we
thought it'd be a good time to talk
about it and we'll be back in a second
and the meantime here is a trailer for
battlefield hardline criminal activity
see if you can spot the dead space
easter egg keep your eyes peeled
coughs forgive
we only streets sometimes you got to
remind them
they won an impasse
and you shot
way high in the steeples and quiet
you one survived you got to have each
other's backs like the boss says I never
let anyone get in your way earlier this
week we sorry no not earlier this week
earlier today CEO I've said a project
red Adam Kaczynski said this year and
the next one will be the year of the
witcher so putting a credence to the
idea that they won't be talking about
cyberpunk 2077 until 2017 Justin this is
a game that we first saw in January of
2013 via that trailer with that rad song
and that cyberpunk lady what do you
think about them not talking or
unveiling anything else about this game
for another two calendar years it's in a
way it makes sense there they put a lot
into the witcher not just with the dlc
coming up but expansions that they're
not being completely forward with but we
know those are coming as well so in that
way it's heartening like they're putting
a lot into the witcher and it's not
going to be a an experience which is
lessened by working on these other games
but at the same time it's that's a long
time to be working on this game and any
time you know it doesn't necessarily
mean something negative it could have
gone through lots of different changes
we haven't seen a lot out of it so is
this something that's gonna make it
better did it go through some troubles
or did it just have to be restarted at
some point yeah you guys were at the
studio recently is that they make hinted
at it all new did you get to talk to so
that no one of the so we saw a bunch of
stuff at CD Projekt when we were there
shooting out the building that's
hahahaha that's their studio rare right
behind it was built by the Soviets yeah
well yeah when we were at their am at
their studio in in Warsaw there was a
couple of little things we saw yeah a
poster mainly yeah there was this one
room we went into where they straight up
told you to stop filming yeah they're
like just put your camera down scribble
can walk through here they're still
working on the witcher though they
weren't like working on that cyberpunk
game yet it didn't seem like so what we
heard there was like a mission statement
we talked about this before yeah and it
just sounded awfully ambitious we sort
of scanned that they said that the the
cyberpunk team had been working i'm not
sure if it was in the separate buildings
they did have another building but they
said that they pulled in everyone
yes of course the witcher would been
delayed I think three times by that
stage and they said that they pulled in
everyone from that team to finish and
with your Wild Hunt and we went into one
of the rooms yeah there was this poster
and the two of us kind of looked at it
and scanned it as much as I try to
remember as much of it as possible and
the only thing I could remember was like
open world role playing so it kind of
sounded like Witcher 3 accept full
choice like branches storyline and
whether this ends up being what it is we
don't know but you have to think if
they're going to spend all that time
making that engine making that type of
game that cyberpunk 2077 is a good
shadow is going to be a game similar to
the witcher 3 in some sort of mechanics
and then you get that other audience
that isn't necessarily taken in by the
fantasy traffic yeah but love is that
science fiction world in the same way
that Blizzard does with World of
Warcraft and Starcraft yeah both of
those audiences yeah because this is
like the first like big mainstream CD
Projekt success like you played all the
other witcha games in the past Andy well
yeah like talk about trying to have not
like we'll have one of those hipster
views about things yeah man you all
coming on which band wig now man I've
been there since beginning no but it's
awesome to see them keeping to their
frickin vision man like mmm witcher's
been such a good game each time it gets
even better and they've like reach I
gained they got a 10 out of 10 on our
site like to reach pinnacle status
basically right and now they're poised
to do another game but I think the
important thing too I don't know how
games are made right and so I do know
that Studios other studios that make
these quote-unquote triple-a games have
like one team working on this yeah that
overlaps with this and then it's like
now we have a release calendar so we can
talk about this at e3 and we'll have
this scheduled to go and then voix blah
blah blah blah CD Projekt is it doesn't
seem to care and their their their own
publisher as well which is super
important so they they go let's make the
best game we can make amid which a3 they
had to pull in everybody like you said
and finish it and then they're like all
right so now let's make the best game we
can make again yep sci-fi and now it's
going to take and they're like let's you
know what let's just not talk about it
for three years because we don't need to
like you know what we can do let's just
make it and then we're gonna go do that
which is super exciting like I'm so I
like it is a long time man but we were
talking to them about the witch
to march into Vince key was saying about
how the biggest problem with two was
that they ran into money and they're
right at a time and I was like a massive
problem you can tell because the ending
of that game like they stripped that
loads of stuff as well where as well as
Hans clearly they had enough time and
resources to make this game hopefully
it's doing enough successfully
financially wise across three platforms
under console released a massive deal
for them money wise to give them the
time to make a really good cyberpunk
game but what another interesting thing
about it was when we were doing the
interviews like somebody interviews were
shot in this like lovely like had like
swords on the ceiling and like a nice
brickwork wall and then it was like a
media room and then there was another in
another media room and then there was
this other room that was all likewise
painted had a crazy futuristic me I
heard like neon lighting on the panels
yeah walls all around the side I'm not
like joke that one of the artists and
was like what is this your cyberpunk
room anyway yeah yeah so they're already
prepping I'd like people were like that
the receptionist at the base was around
aside from 2077 shirt and like loads
people walking around with them and it's
I guess that there was a four-year gap
between witcha too and that was 2011 and
and wild hogs which games is that for ya
so then if they announced well I guess
another four years from now would be 20
19 is that too long to wait for that
size of a developer 150 200 people yeah
I wonder if they'll scale up I don't
know it and then to purr for any kind of
smaller developer as well like as that
game comes out then you know that
they'll be working on whatever their
necks title will be maybe that'll be
another witch or maybe it'll be
something else entirely but you have to
have something that gives all the
different teams something to work on you
have you have people who only do art and
assets aren't actually coding and
creating these things and so once the
game is like fully in process like they
don't have as much do on the game itself
they need to create these worlds that
the computer rendering guys are going to
base it off of and then the gameplay
guys will be able to take that and so
being able to stagger projects gives
each of those teams something to do
without having to lay off yeah yeah
that's true and I wonder like the
artists seem to get really good at
making characters in that medieval
fantasy setting yeah they built a
two-sport they got real like you can
tell from the first to the second game
of the three the the ramp up is
incredible now they have to do that
again I can start from the start
to start from the start yeah yeah with
the new and a new lower which doesn't
have a sort of a grounding like to wish
you didn't in all the in all the books I
guess the last thing to talk about a
relation is people are kind of bomb dad
to take it oh my god cyberpunk we might
be able to play it for like years and
years and years but then i guess the
flip side of this is that if they're
saying that this year and next year are
the years of the witcher then what does
that mean does that mean they're gonna
just make a bunch of expansion packs
that they're gonna keep that open world
man there's a lot of space left on that
like there are one of the expansion
packs we know is a new area does that
mean is gonna be two years like almost
bethesda style of all right here we go
operation hydration all comes back again
at that's an exciting prospect Justin
yeah I think any time that you can get
that much out of a game it's like it's
it's exciting for me as a consumer that
I'm not just buying this game I'm buying
something that's gonna last me for the
next couple of years it's not quite on
the scale of of like an MMO something
that lasts me four for ten years but
then I get to play this game now and I
don't have to say goodbye to it when I
finish it yeah like maybe i'll get to
take a break and try it some other
things and then there's going to be that
next expansion that pulls you in it
makes it a little bit more fun pulls out
the lore makes it works out i love it
when they do stuff like that for four
games that are popular and i mean it
also means that the game is doing well
like that tells you like i made a good
investment in this game and a tee and
other people have as well yeah and the
more people to buy them the more i guess
they'll they'll plan to support this
game because they'll have a bigger user
base of people to purchase expansion
packs in TLC from a lot of people see
that as a as a negative like as a
money-grabbing thing but i think in the
way that modern games are created it's a
necessity like to be able to to build
games at this scale and for that amount
of money you have to have a plan that's
going to stretch out for for at least a
year and as much as you might see like
an expansion is oh we're not done with
the game we had these ideas we're not
able to put them in we're going to
charge you extra money for them like
those are extra things with the witcher
3 and a lot of other games you have a
full experience and this is literally
like which are one point or 3.5 like
it's a it's an additional thing that to
me is is worth it in this kind of case
and he can you confirm this with
cyberpunk 2077 well bottlings oh man
future boxing you two boxes but I it
could happen that thing could still
happen people might you know not not
good families
nected maybe yeah there you go yeah it
would be like red faction insane no it's
all part of the same world it is i'm
[ __ ] established fiction i think it
is i have to actually i never i think
they are taking it yeah like I said yeah
huh cool just taking it all guess we'll
have to wait just another couple years
to find that and let us know you think
of cyberpunk 2077 let us know what
you'll be doing in 2077 when the game
comes out on PlayStation 15 I wonder if
the PlayStation 15 will be it'll be a 14
8660 it would work a be sure well no no
but the game will yeah it'll be real
good in 4k about done I'll be dead how's
your week going on the band before we
close the show what are you working on
this week feels like the quiet before
the storm why are they taking these
notes you guys want to know how much a
1080p monitor yeah good for ya so go
back so we're talking about all these
high numbers right yeah the really
kick-ass 1080p monitor that's an IPS
monitor which I mean I forgot to what it
means but it tells means Grierson it
means like vibrant college better colors
better uh blacks contrast and all that
and all these panels that we were
talking about the high frame rate and
the 4k yeah those are TN twisted nematic
twisted metals you metal something like
that twisted new metal madacorp sound
like a new linkin park i'll be yeah but
that's those those panels actually have
like so you're getting 4k but the color
is actually not quite as oh it so you
don't like edit video on that yeah we
don't edit photos on those even those
four can you watch porn on a later I
mean not that color won't get those
pinks right now you do alright so the
best 1080p monitor according to my boy
over a pc gamer who does great roundups
one hundred forty dollars to give you a
really so like you can either spend a
bunch of money chasing these crazy high
frame rates and high resolutions or you
can spend not a lot of money and get a
really good 1080p monitor by itself is
not gonna give you 4k it's not letting
no don't either resume can really rest
of the stuff to even do it great 1080 so
it's like it just to give you a kind of
famine tip right there straight from the
source just get it the scale is way off
so far i like it so you're gonna spend
the rest of this week researching risers
we getting financing on stuff fine for
loans alright build a 2500 4k machine
yeah like it just kidding
all I just knew all the way you up to
this we have a lot of exciting stuff
coming up for e3 and you know just in
the throes of planning all right how
much stuff can you not talk about yet
have my things this week you doing are
under bar goes everything like is III
gonna be good this year justin know you
say that i'm gonna be going for you
three dude it's gonna be a lot of games
it sounds like all the stuff that you
know you kind of talk about isn't all
the cool stuff yet i right so that's the
great thing is like III there are always
so many secrets that even I don't know
that there are ya there are going to be
things during those presentations that
will light me up that will be a surprise
gee I wonder who knew Brotherhood of
Steel man can you think of anything that
might be coming happening at e3
Brotherhood of Steel Man anything
anything if only he could talk it we
forget in a family doc said we forget to
plug in his power we forgot to this okay
I should end the show Brotherhood of
Steel man I we're done thanks to
everyone for watching this week's show
and we got another live stream on
tomorrow after some reason we're gonna
be doing Collin and Greg live for kind
of funny and here on the couch tomorrow
so stay tuned for that 11 a.m. pacific
time thanks Devon in the back make ish
air Tay da Shaw who else back there spy
route back there no [ __ ] I route in turn
G internet here yeah come get out of
here get any real takeaway Jake up the
engineering is gonna be hanging out for
the next couple months at Jacob the
intern you could just stand behind us
and we'll all uh yeah just stand beside
the with the painting yeah so I said oh
oh he thinks he can get on the couch
already thinks he can get on the catch
Jacob thank you very much for your not
miked up so anything you say he's
completely irrelevant and but I thank
you so much for joining us I mean really
opportunites great he said thank you for
the opportunity that's what he said all
right we're gonna wrap up show thank you
very much for watching jacob lee brown
next week with all your tips Betty three
we're gonna load up full of tips get up
to speed them out here on the show yeah
but we're done for this week so go back
to the witcher 3 by